. We are
going to go next to we're going to Lokey from
Florence.
Now, that's Florence, where Florence could
be in a lot of different places.
That's actually in Florence, Kentucky, northern
Kentucky area.
What's going on?
Not much, they're watching quite a bit now,
just kind of I know for probably about the
last two weeks, I've really been watching
your live stream, looking at a lot of different
stuff going on.
So I just kind of wanted to gauge something
by or at least double check.
So just kind of watching both sides in the
way that this is all advancing and progressing.
I know the Republican Party, the Democratic
Party, they have a lot of issues that they're
going to have to go through, that the president
still faces a lot of people.
Do you see there being any sort of conflict,
military and or otherwise, in between the
party?
A military conflict between the Republican
and Democratic parties, you're saying?
Yes, no, what would that even look like?
I mean, who who would be controlling the military?
Who would be directing the military?
Their point I do know that there are several
militia leaders that are kind of practicing,
I guess.
Oh, OK.
OK, no, no.
But so now that you're asking a different
question, so it sounds like you're asking
is it conceivable that I mean, I'm guessing
you mean pro Trump militias, because that's
that's those are the militias that there are.
It would like a pro Trump militia go so crazy
that the military is out in the streets fighting
the pro Trump militia.
Correct.
OK, that's marginally more likely, I still
find I still think it's relatively unlikely,
but that is marginally more plausible than
than the first scenario, which I think I just
misunderstood.
Yeah, are doing two or three things at once,
but that's my problem.
So I'm curious, what what else are you doing?
Because your phone connection, it's very interesting,
your voice.
It almost sounds like you have a voice modulator
on.
Oh, I've actually got my headphones on, I'm
actually kind of listening.
Gotcha, OK, maybe that it maybe that.
Well, listen, let's hope it doesn't come to
that, OK?
Definitely.
Yeah.
All right.
And is there a siren going off in the background?
It could be I actually live right down the
road from a police station at a fire station
where it's been going off 24/7 around here
going.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call, I appreciate it.
OK, sounds like sounds
like
he's
got